senator Bernie Sanders from Vermont who
is I think one of the greatest
politicians we have in the country he's
an independent which automatically means
he's completely bonkers or at least if
you watch Fox News so he wrote an
interesting piece on Huffington Post
about the Cayman Islands and about how
every corporation in this country is
sheltering money there you thought it
was just Mitt Romney no it's every
corporation from Citibank Bank of
America JP Morgan Chase Goldman Sachs
I mean billions and billions and
hundreds of billions of dollars
there is one building this I love this
there is one five-story office building
in the Cayman Islands that is home to
over 18,000 United States corporations
what do we what do we do about this what
do we do about these companies that we
bail out these big banks that then hide
the money what do we do just I guess
shame doesn't work
I guess literally that when the money is
that high I guess that doesn't work and
that's the one thing that drives me
completely crazy it was one of many
things that drives me completely crazy
is that like you know if you speak out
against something if you're you know
this is the least timely reference of
all times but if you're the Dixie Chicks
and you say something about the Iraq war
you hate America and your records get
burned or whatever but if you take the
money that you make in America and you
move it out of America so that you don't
have to pay for anything in America
that's pretty hateful toward America I
think I mean that's pretty freeloader
ii-in terrified so I don't they don't
make any records that we can burn but I
feel like that sort of need to call them
on some serious America that's even
farther with that America and Americans
ie the people sitting at this table and
the people that are watching helped to
bail you out of billions of dollars of
debt that you've accrued because you are
paying the top level of your bosses as
much money as they could possibly ever
spend in 10,000 lifetimes and you take
and after you've given that bailout when
you all should have been categorically
fired and in some cases take
now backhand shot when you are given
this bailout you don't come back with
the repentant heart you come back even
harder after making more money in the
past couple years since that bailout
then you may before the bailout and you
don't want to pay taxes on that money so
the tax dollars that the Americans gave
you the government gave you to bail you
out you now don't even want to pay taxes
on it's unbelievable it is unbelievable
but no shame doesn't work it's
unbelievable I found out my bank's part
of it like should we are you Bank of
America yeah they're big let me give you
the numbers on Bank of America so in
2010 they set up more than 200
subsidiaries in the Cayman Islands and
received a so they paid no taxes right
in the first place
no US taxes and then the IRS their
rebate was 1.9 billion dollars that's
what Abby's not with an EM so okay if
shames not gonna work and logic isn't
gonna work why is there really nothing
that can work you know we all talked
about this stuff but is there nothing
that can work because I hate to say it
but because the system is rigged them
and we send in politicians that are
bought and paid for we all we all know
this stuff so is there really nothing we
can do when it when stuff gets this so
above where regular people are at I
guess take your money and put it in a
credit union right if everybody got
together and did that it will I think
it's about us taking our money and you
know starting Marcel lachemann is calm
at one of these offices in the Cayman
Islands and we have to do what everybody
else is doing if everybody else is doing
it we should do it I mean literally I
mean then I mean I guess it's like
everybody starts you know bilking the
government out of money then they will
actually move to legislate that you know
what you can't take your money out of
the United States when you make your
money here you have to pay taxes on
everything do you guys think there's
something just so ingrained about how
you can get away with this for example
not to bring everything back to in my
opinion the worst candidate ever
Mitt Romney but he had money hidden in
the Cayman Islands and and that didn't
disqualify him automatically I mean it
was legal but shouldn't that just
morally and in light of the economy and
everything else shouldn't that have just
disqualified the guy just like that that
there should have been a meeting and
they had said you know well you got this
money there so just that uh we're gonna
go a different direction right no but I
think he would have taken it out before
he started running like that would be
something I would do right away you know
no cuz that wouldn't mean he would've
had to bring it back here and you two
actually had to pay taxes are there and
he would have had to actually that's
more shameful right he would have had to
release the fact that he had been not
paying taxes for however many years and
today the thing that I never understood
about Mitt Romney and that base of
people that was really liked about him
was he was probably one of the most
elitist candidates to ever run ever and
how was he gonna how was the man with
the money in the Cayman Islands gonna
even care about the guy in the
Appalachian Mountains who has no shoes
but that guy wouldn't even think of
voting for Obama
47% that is the answer there's it's I
don't like what Mitt Romney did with his
money but it is legal you said it I mean
it's not it's gross it's not ethical
but it's legal what he did he was just
following rules and and maximizing the
amount of his own money but he was able
to keep fine I don't like it but that's
fine I wish that they the people who
defended him
would have the same amount of compassion
for the 47% that don't pay federal
income taxes because it's not like
they're living high off the hog they are
also following the rules they are also
paying payroll taxes they are also
contributing but they are also playing
by the rules you know I mean but but it
seemed like everybody who was Pro Mitt
Romney vilified that percentage of the
country you know I mean absolutely it's
the same thing yeah I mean obviously on
his much much higher what is Mitt Romney
doing with all his money in the Cayman
Islands like I understand what like you
know George Clooney is doing with his
money and they'd be like real rich
people that like are going on bang and
like Stacy Keibler doing you know
high-end things I know what P Diddy is
doing with his money because he's got
the guards and he's got the big cars but
what is Mitt Romney doing with his money
in the Cayman
his buddies working about it's a new
vodka brand his money is just working
for him that's what you know if they're
not like us where we work and we put
money in a bank and then we have to
spend that money out like you're working
for them billion-dollar shopping sprees
and buying a yacht and like you know
does she have like a couple of like
really good-looking like Asian girls in
a house somewhere they just serviced him
and that's all the signs like what are
you doing yeah buddy this you can't pay
taxes on in the United States Mitt
Romney he's hoarding them and they came
in islands to you know what we're just
gonna go with that rumor he's a budget
he is a bunch of Asian women that he